welcome back to middle ground thank you
so much to our sponsors - lien for
making this episode possible stick
around after the episode for a special
offer from - Lane but first here's
middle-ground identity politics I think
that feminism coupled with black lives
matter have done so much more harm than
good in our modern society I'm good not
that good you want me to identify myself
I put myself into a category immediately
identity politics is playing team sports
based on traits about yourself you
cannot change a general way of
categorizing yourself as part of a
greater whole so that could be you know
ethnically based religiously based or I
think it actually could be politically
based - my identity as an American being
an American being a young woman who's a
free thinker Judaism is pretty deeply
ingrained in me I think my empathy are
the questions did everybody do this
human being I think not really think I
know
[Music]
hi my name is Xavier Bryan I am 31 years
old I teach yoga and I'm studying to get
my holistic nutritionist license
hey I'm Jesse I'm turning 32 next week
and I'm a filmmaker hi everyone I'm
Natalie I'm 20 years old and I'm a
business student at USC howdy my name is
domani Felder I'm from San Antonio Texas
I am a salesman and a youtuber right now
my name is Dan I'm 30 I'm a filmmaker
and I'm from Kansas my name is from Nik
Mathur I'm 31 I'm an entrepreneur real
estate broker and author
yeah I mean yeah I feel like the word of
like 2019 is privileged I like to see it
in terms of opportunity I would much
rather the conversation be on
socioeconomic status as a form of
privilege rather than race and this is
what I think was the intention behind
affirmative action in college was to
bring people from underprivileged
communities into higher education and
great higher education at that but what
it's become now has become a tactic to
get in to college I definitely agree
with that some of that I definitely
think that your socioeconomic status
doesn't automatically absolve you from
having experiences that come with being
in a marginalized group
I think privilege is real I think as a
man there are certain things I get to do
and it's hard for me to list all of them
right now in a way that if you know a
woman were to do those things they would
be questioned more they would be doubted
more or people would yeah people would
question them
I believe that there is one privilege
that exists and I think that privilege
is green privilege so when I think about
these things weren't like to say oh well
you are an asian-american wherever you
have certain privileges or things that I
don't have I think what that does it
forces us to inherently say that because
this person is privileged than I am by
default automatically under privileged
and it always allows you to say oh well
this person you know he has a fancy car
or whatever this person has a fancy
vehicle or whatever I can't get that
because that person is a white person
and I'm a black person or that person is
you know a high-ranking executive and
it's a male versus a female look at
Barack Obama a prime example you could
argue oh well he was a person of color
therefore he didn't have the same
privileges or whatever
make no mistake Barack Obama he had
quite a bit of resources from which to
draw sure I agree with that but I just
got it I got it go there is
can you imagine Barack Obama talking
like the current president does and
still getting accepted by the general
public and I can agree that there are
some ways the president tweets that I
don't necessarily
support in the United States you could
argue okay maybe there is a white
advantage right now or in this modern
context you place that white person in
the streets of India it's a completely
different context okay this is a very
we're in a bubble to say that there
there is privilege and there isn't
privileged rich people get overthrown in
countries every day talking about
off-the-books privilege isn't saying
that it's that anything is impossible
for a certain person more than everyone
else is it easy or that ever right it's
also true that some people have
handicaps and we live in a country
specifically talking about this
particular goal because everyone has a
different boat that was made by a bunch
of white men that owned other people and
women couldn't vote what we see now is
from our politicians and people who want
to remain in power or rise to power is
they exploit those characteristics that
make us different we put labels on
everything so I think identity is
intrinsic to who we are as beings even
if there's turmoil or people who are
butting heads I think from that friction
we can spark some members that can
really change a lot of things
I don't believe that I'm going to just
vote for someone because they're black
or because they're male or because
anything that they have in common with
me I don't think that would be the only
reason it would play a part in why I
would vote for that person because of
the experience or wisdom they would have
behind certain social issues that I
experienced as well
to assume that by virtue of someone's
skin color or nationality that they
automatically must know what it feels
like to be me no you don't like no one
knows what it feels like to be me but me
I agree with that
also I think when you have certain
struggles like say you grew up poor and
hungry we would be fighting for that guy
to win right because it's a sense of
coming from the dirt and rising up
that's the American dream really so when
we're talking about someone who's brown
or someone who's Pham you know female or
someone who is black or whatever I think
it's the compassion and the empathy that
they have from coming from that struggle
so that's really what I want for a
leader all humans divide themselves up
into groups naturally and it's up to us
to be able to channel that responsibly
there's a lot of problems in the
discourse right now but I think we're
having conversations now that need to be
had needs to be reckoned
did it create unity within the people
that found solidarity in those movements
absolutely does it create discord
amongst the larger society perhaps
definitely is that discord necessary
probably I would say I think about the
black lives matter all lives matter
thing and as a white person black lives
matter helped me understand a little bit
more about what a black experience could
look like in some situations and it's
not that other lives don't matter it's
just that right now this particular
issue needs a little bit more attention
it's like saying oh well I'm here to
fight for breast cancer and someone else
is like no ill cancers let's do an all
cancer pin it's like not only breast
cancer but why can't we have like well I
can't we have these little moments of
focus on these specific things I'm gonna
start off with a very bold statement I
think that feminism coupled with black
lives matter have done so much more harm
than good
in our modern society there is this
deep-seated resentment that has been
left unaddressed in a lot of the
african-american community but what
matters is the way you channel that and
what you do with it
there's been documented instances where
they say hey white people who are here
get to the back of the group like this
is a black lives matter because like you
said you wanted help but it seems like
you were more preoccupied with being
angry than finding a solution and I
think you're talking right into the
pitfall of identity of politics which is
the common enemy identity politics where
it's it's me against him it's us against
them they're the problem right but
there's another side of identity
politics something more and the likes of
MLK so you draw a larger picture around
a group and then you bring in
commonality where I agree with you is
these movements are losing steam and
lost steam because they didn't
extrapolate from the grievances of the
people if there are systemic issues like
corrupt cops who's four corrupt cops
everyone can get behind that it became
the US versus us versus you it's us
versus them I honestly believe the
organization of the black lives matter
movement was in
in tional that it focused on black
people separating the black experience
from the other experiences is important
because it is specific when you're being
targeted like stop-and-frisk
right it was specific so I could
probably ask have you ever been touched
aggressively by a police officer not
once never in your life not once never
in your life never okay and how many
times have you been like aggressively
searched by a police officer at one time
it was pretty aggressive he said my
license plate lights were out
that's why he pulled me over and they
weren't and he was just kind of slamming
me like over and over and I was like
okay bro you don't have to slam me I'm
not resisting
and then more cop cars came and then
they had me on the ground and they
handcuffed me and they took everything
out of my car and then they uncuffed me
and they said I was free to go but still
that's a traumatic experience I didn't
do anything wrong I wasn't speeding
whatever you know I mean I'm in a white
neighborhood no one's saying there isn't
prejudice or racism in in any type of
situation but that's a that's a cultural
dynamic that we need to address as a
society and community that isn't
something you can regulate out like I
can't regulate someone to respect me but
that's why civil rights is important
because you can't force you know people
to say black people I like black people
but you can't say they get to vote now
it's about rallying people in order to
change policy so I wanted to speak on
the feminist movement really quickly I
would call myself a feminist in the
literal sense of the definition if we're
talking about the political
socio-economic and social equality of
the sexes I think there's a lot of
people I think the majority of Americans
would agree with that definition but
what feminism has done now is it's gone
completely to the other side in which
case pro-life feminists aren't invited
to the conversation anymore women that
support Trump and yes we do exist we're
not invited to the conversations anymore
because we're automatically seen as that
at face value I struggle with these
extremes right whether it's just good or
just bad I think that the 24-hour news
cycle and algorithms on Facebook and
Twitter and Instagram are damaging to
the country because they
help us and get into our trenches even
deeper encouraging identity politics in
a negative we have people who would
rather talk about oh this is what your
racism this is almost what your
prescribed set of values this is what
your thought process should look like
and I think when we apply that lens to
every situation that we abdicate the
ability to critically think for
ourselves when we are always self
segregating ourselves based on those
things that make us different just
because you have a common trait doesn't
mean you have a shared experience right
you know and it might be true in one
scenario right but what happens in the
mainstream is we start conflating
several different experiences with the
same common trait and that's where the
idea kind of implodes on itself I guess
I agree with most of what everyone
brought up it is reductive to reduce
your thoughts and perspectives just to a
group or a race and I would just like
first of all like growing up in Kansas
like an Asian identity was never really
discussed amongst me or my friends or
anyone I knew it wasn't until I became
an adult moved somewhere like Los
Angeles where people are interested in
having a discussion that I started to
see what that was like what that
experience was like and not saying if a
candidate is agent I automatically agree
with them but there are certain things
that people treat me as that people
wouldn't treat you as wouldn't treat you
as and it's helpful for me to realize
those things without saying that I'm
totally identified by that and
furthermore I feel like we need more
discussion because like look at things
like the college admissions thing people
are saying that there's too many Asians
in college and they're actually pitting
Asians against black people for a lot of
these slots it materially affects
people's lives to have these discussions
so I think it's valuable so you can't
say oh well we need to see X amount of
this race in college because that's fair
that isn't fair what's fair is anyone
that wants to be here can try to be here
but race has been used to exclude people
from institutions as well and
definitely agree that entering into
college now that we've lifted those
bands on who can go and enter into these
institutions I definitely agree that
there should be a framework where race
isn't involved
I think identity politics are like a lot
of things it can be misused but we have
to understand what the caveats are and
the limitations and in in that framework
I think identity of politics is very
useful there was someone in my groom's
party and I was like my wife and I
didn't know how to handle it and I asked
whether he would want to be like how I
would introduce him to the rest of my
grooms party and I'm embarrassed
thinking back on that now because that
put them in a difficult situation but
thank goodness there their heart was big
enough and they were kind enough and
understanding enough to be able to say
just introduced me as a guy that's what
I am that's my gender identity I'm trans
it's good for people to understand
gender it now they're creating the
language around it being a social
construct which is in itself definitely
very true we don't have a framework set
up right now where that can be fluidly
expressed because we will box people in
based off of how they look but
identifying is important so we can free
up that truth and people can really just
feel much more autonomous with their
identity brilliantly said now what we're
learning as science is that gender is a
spectrum okay so how feminine you are or
how alpha male you are is a spectrum and
on that spectrum we fall so how many how
many of these pronouns do we need are
there a billion variations that we can
genetically identify like what I'm
trying to get at is I think we're too
closely tying our gender and eye to our
to who we are just going off of the
prompt is is it reasonable for people to
learn new gender per
the question is how many because today
I'm not sure how if I look at Facebook I
think there's like there's a multitude
of different gender identities and at
some point we have to ask ourselves okay
well where do we draw a line for what is
reasonable how many names do you think
it's appropriate to get someone to learn
here's my honest opinion male/female
like I feel like that's enough to get
the gist of what you're experiencing you
cisgender right you you are agreeing
with the gender you were given at Birth
yes honestly you're not really going to
be able to feel into an experience of
someone who doesn't identify with either
who identifies with both who identifies
with one opposite of the other I don't
think it's reasonable to force someone
else to call you by whatever you
identify as now I know I already know
people in the comments or get y'all had
fun do your thing I don't care but
here's the thing for a group for a group
that claims to champion tolerance and
shoe diversity what I have seen
overwhelmingly is a lack of willingness
to accept what other people think
peoples and yet amis are highly
emotional it's a demo it's an emotional
point every time you tell somebody your
ethnicity or your racial breakdown it is
going to spark some sort of feeling
whether that's negative or positive and
I think identity politics preys on the
negative feelings we feel about
ourselves and how we're viewed in the
world
[Music]
this is a tricky one because like do I
think it's possible anytime in the near
future that were anywhere close to it
right now
probably not but is it something that I
would like to live into and that I think
we could all move towards yeah well I
would say it's possible because they're
only going to remain fixtures of debate
as long as we allow them to if we can
actually find a way to stop making that
the cornerstone of every ideological
dispute I think we can get there but we
divide ourselves into groups whether
it's how we look
whether it's our gender whether it's how
much money we make I feel like if as
long as we're human we're always gonna
do that and so I always feel like it's
going to be a factor what kind of factor
that is whether there's a hierarchy to
things and those hierarchies interact in
complicated ways so it's not always
clear-cut I think that's something we
can fix and make better but I think
we're always gonna have differences it's
just a fact well yeah - you're part of
the humans innately we always have to
have to have to have this a superiority
complex on those so I get your point on
that I do I do
I think it'll always be a factor but how
we act with each other how we respond to
each other is a completely different
story and it doesn't have to be mutually
exclusive ideas there's this
contradiction between diversity and
inclusion that keeps coming up like
what's wrong if we're different it's
okay
what's wrong if we're the same it's okay
I like that
I honestly think as human beings we're
going to be able to unravel our biases
and as we do that then we won't create
policies that disenfranchise certain
groups once we get rid of that
unraveling that bias will just all be
able to see each other as human beings
because that's really what it's about
it was really great to see Dan that
episode absolutely and it's cool because
we have these conversations during lunch
so it's cool to see them outside the
office and on the screen in this episode
we dealt identity in terms of race and
gender but in today's day and age it's
also important to keep in mind your
digital identity specifically keeping it
safe thank you to our sponsors - Layne
for making this episode of middle-ground
possible - Layne generates and securely
stores all of your passwords for any
website across all three devices so you
never have to click forgot password
again passport info credit card banking
info Wi-Fi passwords all of it autofill
so you can always have everything on
hand on any device which is especially
great for when you travel there's also a
VPN so you won't be tracked and can
access any content when you're browsing
the Internet and other countries and for
your good humans out there if you want
to try - Layne what a - Lang comm
Jubilee get your first device for free
and when you're ready to upgrade to
premium use promo code jubilee for 10%
off so again a big thank you to - Layne
thank you we heard they loved middle
ground and we love that you guys love it
we'll see you guys next time